hello everyone how's everybody doing
welcome to rational science
why are we rational well because
everybody else is
irrational either irrational or
supernatural
if you look at the so-called scientific
method that most people out there follow
it's the what i call the mathematical
method
it's not the scientific method but the
mathematical method the eminem
uh they make an observation they ask a
question
they form what they call a hypothesis
whatever that is
there's like 10 different definitions
for what a hypothesis
is and a one of them is that it's a
testable
explanation and what you won't find in
mathematical physics today
anywhere is explanations
explanations specifically for
the intangible invisible phenomena that
occurs out there
you know light gravity magnetism you
won't find
a rational physical interpretation
anything at the cosmic level or at the
you know a quantum level the uh
subatomic level you won't find a
rational explanation
and so the word explanation this is not
for me this by the way from another site
but
they have this idea that there are
explanations no there are
no explanations there are descriptions
that's all that mathematics can do
all they can do is describe what is an
equation
a description it doesn't explain
anything okay so
we don't have explanations and that's
the problem with the so-called
scientific method all these people
follow it's really the mathematical
method
uh they make predictions i don't know
what predictions have to do with science
predictions i thought astrologers made
predictions
okay and they test the predictions they
do experiments
and then they iterate they use the
results to make a new hypothesis or a
new prediction
you know or in fact that's one of the
definitions of hypothesis that it's a
prediction
so uh yeah all these people have um this
what they call the scientific method we
call it the mathematical method why
because these people are not into
explaining first but
second they're only describing but
second there's the issue
that um all of this
has to do with persuading convincing
converting and recruiting people that's
how it is this is about
trying to influence the jury that's all
that this is for this is
to try to convince you that they're
right that they got the truth that they
found proof and evidence and all this
stuff
we don't do that in science we that's
what they do in religion
you know when you go on to sunday school
they try to convert you
that's what this is all about this is
about converting people not about
explaining
a phenomenon objectively and it turns
out that
explaining a phenomenon objectively is
regarded as
oh that's philosophy so um
here we have what is it a magnet
attracts another magnet
okay okay
this is philosophy explaining this is
philosophy
why because you can't see the mediator
is that why this is philosophy
it's opinion that's all it is
all they do is mathematics to explain to
describe
how fast or what force or how how strong
the attraction is that's it
that's just a description that's physics
or is physics explaining how mother
nature does this
invisible trick or you know you let go
of pen
pencil you know pen let's see if i can
do it with you
watching here okay so i let go of the
pen
uh yeah it's a pen and uh
it falls to the floor and you can do the
experiment at home every day you'll see
it always falls to the floor
you drop spoons to the floor you drop
cups
it falls they fall to the floor uh
is that philosophy explaining that
and that's what these people are saying
that's all philosophy we don't do that
what we do here is math and we call
those descriptions
science so you describe a chair you know
four legs a
back seat a backrest and a seat and
you did science great now we do
something else here we try to explain
and here is
our the contrast to what these people do
okay
and here you can see it uh rational
scientific method
we have a hypothesis an assumption and
it includes the object's definitions
and the initial scene why because we're
going to try to explain
objectively to someone how mother nature
does her
invisible tricks okay
so the issue here is trying to explain
you can see there are little different
these two
scientific methods so-called scientific
methods theirs is mathematical
okay and then we go into the theory the
mechanism itself the causes
and finally we reach some conclusions
okay
so uh yeah we have a different version
of the scientific method and we call
that
the rational scientific method okay
and what do we come up with as a result
of that well we come up with this we
come up with the
uh rope model we're saying that uh we
ended up with a different conclusion
we're saying that every atom in the
universe is connected to all
others all there is out there really is
a single
closed loop thread and this uh single
thread
goes all around the universe to every
bit of matter
every galaxy every star every planet
every asteroid every atom
and uh the single thread
just twines around in different
directions forms the
atoms those atoms are obviously
connected to the other atom they're
connected through a twine
pair of threads same thread and the
atoms themselves are made of these
threads
and when the atoms expand and contract
they torque the rope
which is pulled tight in other words
it's drawn tight
and by torquing the rope light travels
in both directions
in what we call a torsion of the rope
that's what it is essentially
that's what it all comes down to okay
and with this as you can see we can
explain
light first of all okay and second of
all we're going to explain also gravity
here's the
version of gravity if all atoms are
interconnected
then we don't need to use any fancy um
explanations out of the ordinary you
know or saying oh we don't understand it
now here you have a mechanism as uh the
astronaut falls down to earth the ropes
fan out
and he goes at an ever faster rate not
because the ropes are pulling
i want to make sure that people
understand people think that the ropes
are pulling
the ropes are not pulling as the
astronaut occupies
locations closer to the earth the ropes
that connect
every atom in his body to every atom on
earth
i didn't draw them all uh
they fan out they're they're all at
different angles the closer he gets to
earth and that is the acceleration of
gravity right there
okay so we have a mechanism for light we
have a mechanism also for
uh electricity and magnetism and the
workings of the atom which
are not shown there but it gives you an
idea that yeah we come from a different
angle
all together and here i guess you can
say is the summary okay this is the
difference between
what everybody else does out there which
they do with particles
whether they use waves or torsion
not torsion but vortices it's all uh
either concepts or particles and and the
concepts are founded on
particles a wave transverse wave is what
the movement the the waving of the
particles
what's waving well particles or you have
to say what a lot of mathematicians say
it's the waving of nothing they have to
say some stupid thing like that no
we're saying all atoms are
interconnected and there is no waving
up and down what there is is a torsion
you know uh if this is the rope okay
what we have is a torsion and when you
have a torsion
it goes not only fast and explains the
speed of light
but it goes both ways it goes in both
directions from
atom to atom my hands are the atoms in
this case okay
so if you torque that obviously a little
faster than what i can do here
um the atoms expand and contract torque
the rope
and that torsion is what we call light
very simple well what has happened well
for the last hundred years the religious
folk have taken over science
and they just say uh we don't understand
it
but we've proven it we've got equations
we have experiments all this proves
our theories that's all they can tell
you but then they say well it's
unimaginable you cannot imagine
uh four-dimensional space-time you
cannot imagine a particle being at two
places at once as the uncertainty
principle
requires or demands or entails okay
and uh so we have these people that uh
have you know when we invented tv
all these people started started uh
doing shows
for the public and so these are some of
the uh
people who have gone in there let me
give me a second i'll turn this thing on
and uh here you have it these are people
who
were on tv i think they're all dead now
okay but here they are and uh
what they did uh you haven't people like
don herbert jax cousteau uh
carl sagan and stephen hawking and uh
what they did
they eventually passed on the baton to a
new generation
of people okay and um
let me get this
and the new generation essentially
inherited the same thing that all these
people did here's the new
or not the newest but this is the next
generation that inherited from these
folks
let me give me a second here these uh
people took over from that older
generation you can say okay here you
have brian greene
neil tyson bill nye and jim alkali a guy
i've been talking about
lately okay and these folks are getting
old
or are old now and what they did is uh
they uh turned a baton to a new
generation of folk and
these are the new folks uh you have
people like michael stevens matt
o'dowd uh derek miller and nick lund
uh nick lucid and all these people
are the ones who are now uh
passing on the baton to the new
generation these are
what are they doing they're explaining
and
i hate to use the word explain because
they don't explain anything but what
they're doing is
passing on what they learned in college
by road without
questioning or even if they questioned
they finally were overcome
by the arguments and they just pass on
what they learned what they memorized to
the public and of course in in the last
hundred years they haven't invented
anything because the
real solution was to get rid of the
particle hypothesis
what has happened is they cannot explain
anything why because they're using
particles
to simulate everything and they say well
you know we can't understand it
of course you can't because you're
dealing with particles with discrete
particles
and for sure you cannot explain pull the
force of pull with particles
what doesn't exist in all of quantum
mechanics and all of
uh general relativity essentially also
in string theory
there's no pull you have no pull you
have no way of producing pull because
everything is mediated by discrete
entities
and that's where the problem comes in
what they should have done is apply
porparian falsifiability and say look
all these experiments 100
of them 150 of them
falsify the particle hypothesis that's
what they should have done
instead of that they created all these
ridiculous principles
uncertainty complementarity and who
knows what you know equivalence
okay so this is this is where we are at
now but it turns out because they don't
produce anything new
they don't have anything new to offer
they had to
invent new things for the new for the
new generation
to do they had to branch off go on
tangents that not are not really
related to physics directly or are
maybe tangential and one of those
was doom the extinction of man doomsday
okay
and so uh this is where they went uh
if i can find it here
there he goes
they went into doomsday and they use
their equations
to try to see if they can figure out
when man is going to become extinct
listen to that they're using equations
to tell you
yes we will become extinct or we won't
become extinct
and if we do i'll tell you when more or
less
that's what this uh whole argument is
about that's what i'm going to be
talking about today
the doomsday argument these people claim
that equations can tell them because
equations tell them everything right
tells them how the universe runs tells
them
um why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system that's this
uh warped time that's there right and
yeah because they can do everything with
equations they think they can also tell
you when we're gonna die
and when we're you know what's uh when
when we're gonna be
uh when we're gonna
finish our days our species okay that's
that's essentially what these people are
saying
okay and uh for that they came up with
this this this group of people right
these are the people who today
essentially
spread the doomsday argument okay and
you probably recognize some of them uh
from either tv or from youtube or
whatever
and again you have some of them are the
same people i just mentioned michael
stevens and
this matter of dog you have nick boxtrom
he's supposedly a
philosopher of physics or who knows of
science and he's
much into the doomsday argument and in
martin reeves and
there there's so many people involved in
this i mean if you look at the um
if you look at the literature that has
balloon since about 1970s
in fact really after the world world war
ii and i'll explain that in a second
uh it's balloon the number of papers
written
on issues such as the anthropic
principle
and doomsday scenarios is simply
incredible and i'm not talking about
unknown people i'm talking about
you know the the high people people that
you would recognize their names if
you've
read a little bit about physics so where
did all this start
i think it started around uh world war
ii uh towards the end of the war what
happened they
had invented by then the atomic weapons
and for those who believe it i mean the
flat earthers don't believe it but
for those who believe it you know they
dropped two bombs in japan they killed
lots of people
supposedly like a hundred thousand
people in each city or so
so thereabouts and what happened
uh suddenly everybody got this idea that
whoa we have the weapons to destroy
mankind
see until then everybody just had or at
least a religious folk you know they had
traditional religions
uh they had this notion that okay jesus
christ is gonna come
at the millennium or the second
millennium and take
all those chosen ones to heaven so it
was vague
it was yeah maybe who knows but now
we had reality on our hands here we had
this weapon
this this uh cannonball that could
destroy a hundred thousand people
and and so people said oh hold it and
then and then the russians got it
as well the soviets and i was part of uh
involved in some of that you know and uh
so so now we had these two
mafias you know the on the one hand the
soviets on the other hand the u.s
government and each one had the bomb
okay
and they were building more bombs
eventually they built these missiles and
so on and now we have the ability to
destroy mankind
you know just by pressing buttons and so
yeah what grew out of that was this
notion that
we are a little fragile uh we can't
guarantee our existence because you
don't know
we get a crazy guy up there he decides
to press the red button and that's it
for all of us you know
we start exchanging bombs so people had
uh
suddenly this notion that humanity was
mortal
we were aware of our mortality as a
species
that it could happen we we could really
kill ourselves
and because of that what what happened
was they invented this thing
in 1947 they invented the doomsday
clock okay and the doomsday clock
was uh put in there because yeah every
time there was tension
uh in the political world right
and uh soviets did not get along with
the americans for some reason
people were scared and they started
moving that hand on the clock saying oh
we're closer to to death for our species
and it's a 12-hour clock
and you can see that they don't even put
buttons or
or or markers for anything below
nine o'clock it's from nine to twelve
it's like they move
back and forth like how close are we to
pressing the buttons okay
uh for nuclear extinction in other words
by
by war right and um
lately in fact they had they moved it up
they moved it
uh to about if i can get it up here
oh yeah uh they moved the the hand on
the clock even closer like 100 seconds
from midnight or from 12 o'clock right
so
uh you know they they're afraid that
not only the possibility of nuclear war
because there are tensions in different
parts of the world
but now they've been introduced new
factors they said oh hold it we have
climate change
and we're destroying the environment and
maybe there's a disease that runs amok
maybe made by the cia the kgb or the
chinese
uh uh secret service and um
and then you know they and then maybe we
invent ais and so on
so so the list for the doomsday clock
has
increased here's a just a very brief
list
okay nuclear war climate change
environmental destruction we're
destroying the environment
uh cyber warfare you know we're playing
around with the computers
uh all these uh the ca in uh
it's probably tries to break into the uh
chinese uh
uh mainframes and vice versa you know so
these people are
all fighting the cyber war trying to
influence each other maybe the elections
or whatever
uh public opinion and uh so all this
makes people nervous and uh the people
who run the clock they keep moving that
hand back and forth you know like
we're closer now to extinction or now
now we're a little farther away
and one of the big ones lately obviously
is this
climate change a lot of people are
concerned about that's in the news
all the time okay okay so uh what
happened around 1973
father comes up his name is brandon
carter i think he's uh
jimmy carter's brother
and this uh followed brandon carter he
came up with the anthropic
principle and um you say well what does
that have to do
with doomsday with the end of man
and yeah the entropic principle
essentially says that
uh the universe is fine-tuned for life
okay that already gives you an idea that
if it's fine-tuned for life
well just maybe right just maybe um
it's uh also fine-tuned for death
right possibility there and so uh what
happened as a result of that well about
10 years later
uh in his that article
that i just put up there he talked about
how the entropic
principle might be related to how much
life there is in the universe
you know there's uh this issue about
fermi's paradox that
uh if if there's some other life out
there we think that
some of it at least should be older than
ours and more advanced in ours and
so how come they haven't contacted us
are we the only life in the universe
so brandon carter analyzed this issue
like he said
you go to a planet you find some people
there or some
life and does that prove that life is
um very popular out there
or or are we in the same boat we're
saying okay now we have two
pieces of evidence that there's life in
the universe does that tell us that
life is very uh widespread or that
life is a very scarce resource in the
universe what does it tell us
uh right now we're the only example
we've got out there
and so uh we have one data point
and can you extrapolate much from that
okay so
so this is one of the issues okay but
the fine-tuning took us to a different
level
it was related to the doomsday scenario
to
to the extinction of man you say how how
so
well here's an example this is uh from
my website i modified it a little bit
okay just to give you
an idea how some of the uh
physical variables or physical uh
relations out there do affect life on
earth okay
now just give you an example here okay
and this is uh this is the example i
have in my website and it goes something
like this
if the earth is closer to the sun right
or farther away those do
those two blue circles there you know if
the earth is closer or farther away we
have more heat or less heat
um if it's outside of the ecliptic the
earth is outside the ecliptic you know
maybe that has an effect on life
maybe if the tilt of the earth is
different maybe if it's got a different
magnetic field or none
at all the sun size if the sun were
bigger or smaller
the mass of the earth right if if the
earth has more mass
uh gravity would be greater if the
earth has less mass you know maybe would
be we would be
uh taller people you know or the
giraffes would
be longer um
you know what effect those do those
things have on life so so yeah some of
those parameters
out there do affect life especially the
heat the mass etc right
and uh but these people went with the
constants that they had found through
um quantum mechanics okay and so
uh these are some of the issues that
they brought up
okay or that they were studying okay
and a typical example here i just give
two examples
one is the uh fine structure constant
characterizes the strength of the
coupling of an elementary charged
particle with the electromagnetic
magnetic field by the formula blah blah
blah blah blah
if alpha there right were to change by
four percent
okay stellar fusion would not produce
carbon
we don't have carbon we don't have us
okay so keep that in mind
so that carbon-based life would be
impossible if alpha were greater than
0.1
stellar fusion would be impossible and
no place in the universe would be warm
enough for life as we know it
so just by changing that alpha you know
which is a
ratio 1 over 137 um
if we could change that number they say
that to some degree
right life would probably have been
impossible here
on earth that's one of the arguments
okay otherwise this cosmological
constant
and again there's several of these now
i'm just picking two here
and um that's the dark energy of which
space is made
and it overcomes you know the
gravitational attraction of matter
uh remember uh einstein said it was his
biggest blunder when he included that
cosmological constant
that's what that is essentially it's you
know gravity would pull everything
together in the universe
okay that's that's what you would expect
and it turns out that
uh hubble edwin hubble in 1929
1931 i think it was he showed that or
at least this was his theory right some
people believe it
mathematicians believe it that the
universe is expanding
and galaxies are flying away from each
other okay
everything is red-shifted out there
that's that's the argument
and uh because everything is flying away
the universe is
expanding and you're saying hold it then
the gravitational con
the cosmological constant is
actually you know a positive number and
all these uh
um things are being
pushed away means that there's something
doing that and that's the
dark energy that they talk about it's
that dark energy pushing
mass away when mass tries to attract
mass you know
uh the uh galaxy tri tries to attract
our galaxy what pushes it away what
overcomes that attraction that
gravitational attraction
is the cosmological constant
which is just a number for the dark
energy this invisible energy that
allegedly pushes galaxies apart
okay so that's the general notion of
dark energy
and here we have a nobel prize winner uh
stephen weinberger and he tells us
uh why is this taking so long here uh
and he tells us why that's important for
life or for death for the end of man
weinberger
weinberg explains that if the vacuum
energy took different values in
different domains of the universe
the formation of life supporting
structures would be suppressing domains
where
the vacuum energy is much larger okay
specifically if the vacuum energy is
negative and its absolute value
is substantially larger than it appears
to be in the observed universe
say a factor of 10 larger holding all
other variables
constant that would mean that the
universe is closed so they're talking
about whether the universe is closed
open flat you know that sort of thing
its lifetime would be shorter than the
age of our universe we're already
putting a limit on the expansion of man
by saying hey you know
the universe doesn't go forever okay
possibly
um too short for intelligent life to
form
okay in other words on the other hand a
universe with a large
positive cosmological constant would
expand
too fast preventing galaxy formation
according to weinberg
domains where the vacuum energy is
compatible with life would be
comparatively
rare so that would explain maybe
right why we can't find life out there
uh maybe we are an exception and so
these people are trying to figure all
this out through a mathematical angle
they're saying okay maybe the equations
maybe the variables maybe the constants
that we've got out there
that they've come up with been able to
measure they say
maybe those have to do something with
life with this anthropic
principle the fact that they're
fine-tuned
for life and it gives you an idea that
these
these people really without them knowing
they're talking about design
uh they're talking about a watchmaker
here you know they're saying look uh
it's just by sure coincidence that all
these constants
are in such uh concordance with each
other
that it allows for life because if some
of those constants were different
we would be here and hopefully they
don't change
maybe they stay the way they are because
if they change well that's the
extinction of man right there you know
so hopefully you know
the proton mass stays the same electron
mass all the
all this stuff you know velocity of
light all that stuff hopefully
stays the same because if any of that
were to change well who knows maybe
that will kill us so you see how they're
bringing us in they're saying oh we have
to get into the extinction business
because our math tells us that maybe
just maybe
this tells us something about why we're
here in the first place
and why we may not be here in the future
if any of this
happens to change okay so that's where
they're going with all this
so what happened uh about 10 years after
uh carter wrote his uh 1983 uh
paper this fellow comes up
and he comes up with a doomsday argument
that essentially
is the most popular the one that's being
used today okay
and uh so what does uh mr god say
well essentially he uh he has this uh
argument and here let me
i try to illustrate it and it goes
something like this
this thing up here okay you have two
hats okay you put
10 or 15 uh papers
with numbers in them one through 15 or
whatever
uh in the top hat in the 10 gallon hand
you throw a thousand papers or a million
papers whatever you want
okay you whatever fits okay
now you ask someone to pull a number out
of one of the hands they don't know what
number
what hat they pulled it out of and they
say okay i got the number four
so they pulled the number four you look
at it and say well hold it
what uh hat do you think you pull this
one out of
well if you have a million papers in the
10 gallon hat
you know the likelihood of pulling out a
four
is almost you know incredible no no you
would say no i
probably i'm mostly lightly i'm almost
95
sure that i pulled it out of the top hat
because it's more likely to pull a four
out of one through 15
and to pull a four out of one out of a
million okay
so that's that's essentially uh the
analogy that they use
and then they go into the uh extinction
uh
theory itself and it's got to do with
how much time we have left
okay and here is uh essentially my
uh illustration of that okay here it is
okay let's say
um you don't know whether you are one of
the last humans on earth or one of the
first humans
on earth in other words how many humans
have there been
and how many humans will there be ever
assuming you know we're we're not
eternal assuming
uh there we have a say
trillions of humans let's say we have 1
trillion humans or 10 trillion humans
well if you're if we ever have 10
trillion humans
you are just a small percentage of that
you're in the like in the 5 percent
uh region you know 100 billion people
that supposedly lived until today
and died they only form like five
percent of all the humans that will ever
live
and if and if we live in eternity well
that number goes from five almost to
zero
it approaches zero the longer we live
unless the universe
you know explodes or dies or whatever on
the other hand
if we're close to if the hundred billion
are almost all the people that are ever
going to live
well then maybe we're in the 90
percentile region you know we
we are among the last humans to be
living on the planet
that's the end of our species so this is
essentially the argument either
either humans are going to live for
thousands and thousands of years
you know maybe millions of years and we
are just a small portion of the humans
that have
that will ever live you know we started
if we assume like that
we started 200 000 years ago the 200
000 years from a small percentage of the
trillions of years we have ahead of us
and so in that sense we're only five
percent or less of the humans that
will ever live on the other hand if we
are the last humans on earth and the two
hundred thousand years are essentially
all that humans will ever live well then
you're in the last
group and you're within the maybe the
last 90 or
or 95 of humans that will ever live
so that's essentially what the got
argument was the doomsday argument
that's the most popular there are
different versions by the way
okay so well a lot of the criticism here
has to do with you know we don't know
how many humans will ever live
uh all we can do is guess and so
you know we haven't learned anything
from math in this regard
this is just playing around with
equations to say well what if
that's it does it tell us anything about
reality does it tell us anything about
extinction of man it doesn't
and um it doesn't because you know again
we don't know
how many humans will ever live uh do we
have a thousand
years in front of us a million years we
don't know we don't know if there's
going to be
trillions of humans or the 100 billion
that we've got so far 107 i think it is
107 billion
that's it for man maybe we reach 110
billion and that's it
and maybe we've got 3 billion to go
maybe 2 billion 1 billion
do we know no obviously mathematics
cannot tell us
anything because this is a qualitative
issue
but if they want to do numbers they
should have done numbers like i do
okay so here's here's my numbers okay
and i got this uh
these numbers i just pulled them out uh
out of the
um wikipedia and uh these numbers
reflect what the demographers
have collected over the last two
thousand years what they say
happened as far as population for the
last two thousand in fact
when you get to two thousand you get
even more variation between
demographers they start coming more or
less together about
the year 500 okay so that's when i
started my
my calculation here okay if i can get
this thing up here
okay
okay and uh so if you started the year
500 there were maybe 200 million people
on the planet
by the year a thousand we had 300
remember uh
uh by the year 1500 we had a loss of uh
people because of the bubonic plague
millions
people died maybe a third to a half of
europe but
we recover by we recovered that
population more or less by 1500 we have
maybe 500
1700 we had like 600 and so on down the
line
by the time you get to 1900 okay now we
have to go by decades because you know
we started
increasing by the hundreds of millions
okay
and you can see the numbers just in the
last 100 years
how they went up dramatically and
you know we were in 1900 we were at a
thousand six hundred
uh 1.6 billion people
and in just a hundred years 120 years
we're up to
7.6 billion maybe even more maybe we're
closer to 8 billion
so we've expanded rapidly and
i think this tells us a little more than
what the
doomsday argument tells us about you
know where we're headed
and especially when you include this
this
other graph okay uh here here's the
well here's that pictorial version of
that
i don't know why these things are taking
so long today to upload okay
uh you can see what happened just a
pictorial version okay and
uh so if you go in there and you look at
the uh
other piece of important piece of data
that i include and that's the declining
birth rate
since uh 1963
our birth rate our growth rate has
gone down and by the year 2050
maybe a little further if things
continue as they are we're going to
reach zero population growth that means
you know uh
population is not going to increase
anymore so maybe reach 9 or 10 billion
and that's it that's it for humanity you
know we're
we're just gonna stabilize we're we're
gonna remain more or less
with the same population forever and
ever supposedly right
and uh so if i put that graph that you
just saw and i put it onto my curve of
life
okay the question is what's going to
happen
after we reach that zero population
growth are we going to
continue growing exponentially or
whatever
are we going to oscillate back and forth
more or less
stabilize on a constant population maybe
9 10 billion people
or are we gonna head down like i say all
the way down to extinction to zero
which one which of those three curves
are we going to follow and yes we are
going to follow one of those three
curves because there is no other option
we either continue
growing we stabilize or we go down
okay that's it and so
it's up to you to determine you know
which of those curves
uh we're going to follow and right now
like i said you know we are
uh our our growth rate is going down
so we're headed towards that point where
i doubt very much we're going to take
that
uh exponential curve upwards uh
no i think it's either going to be uh
constant
more or less constant it's oscillating
around some value
or we're going to go down to extinction
and what i choose is the one
for extinction not because i'm a
pessimist no i'm
realistic okay so it's not pessimistic
it's realistic
okay what's my point my point is that
you can't determine anything
doomsday through mathematics mathematics
was not designed
to um to tell you anything
no explanation you don't have
explanations in mathematics all you have
is descriptions and these people are
trying to get
explanations out of values out of
constants that they've
determined out there okay and so here's
my conclusion on this
okay for these mathematicians okay
uh the entropic principle it's just an
attempt to determine through equations
whether the universe is fine-tuned for
life well that's like a
bootstrap mechanism like you know
tautology that's all it is and the
doomsday argument is an attempt to
determine three equations again
mathematics
whether the extinction of man is
imminent
you know they try to put throw equations
numbers at the thing
and again that's you're never going to
find out through equations
but you can find out maybe through the
numbers uh uh
qualitative things such as you know the
birth rate
uh that might tell you a little more
than what these people are saying here
okay so that's in a nutshell what i
think of their
doomsday argument and again if you look
it up
you'll find tons of literature that has
been published in the last i guess
uh 60 or so years on
on this issue of doomsday in the
anthropic principle
absolute nonsense but these people have
nothing to do and so they
branched out into this uh realm and it
does create some job security for a lot
of these uh
mathematicians i think that's all that
is
treat it with a pinch of salt